[Music]
you and Shaq have kind of a fun rivalry
back and forth he's always picking on me
you know Conan I'm a pretty easygoing
guy I'm not bothering anybody
but he's always picking on me well he I
don't know if you know this because you
don't follow social media I do not he
instagrammed this picture of you
[Applause]
Wow yeah why is he doing this to you
what about it seems like he want to see
me naked want to see me naked
you know how choose not to do in a
social media so I'm not gonna take any
shots back at him right if you don't
mind we'll get him for you we actually
had this picture made up and we're gonna
blast this out I didn't think anybody
could screw up the data step that's not
awful thing to think about it's a
terrible thing to think about you do
Capital One ads okay but you give Shaq a
hard time for all the endorsements he
does because he got a hundred of them
you think he's do you think Shaq is is
is doing too many endorsements too many
commercials well he's got do I think
yeah he got two million dollars and you
know he's got the lotion every
commercial it was like a shark
commercial where on television so we're
not on doing the game we sit in the
greenroom
he's on every five seven eleven lotion
on his fake body but there's not his
body
that's not his body - trust me that's
not his body
you know I think I figured out why he
does rub lotion on his body all the time
that's all when they can get his fat ass
in a Buick
[Applause]
every commercial and man up and then the
Buick commercial comes on you know gets
fat ass can fit in the Buick it must
have shot toes the same day he's been
like the first eight I was putting on
lotion then like pushing it
yeah